good to have you on the show now am i uh
pronouncing your name correctly because
it's an unusual
sudaikis yes yes yeah it's lithuanian
all i don't know much about my heritage
because i said cb ass earlier yeah no
that that'll fly it'll be fine i'm i'm
used to everything
i get i get a bunch of different things
but uh and it's awesome awesome hearing
you say it
even though a little wrong but uh but
one of the best
what is it past progressive have you
ever done accepted no i'm sure you'll
get it right next time
uh no uh there'll be no next time
um but you know the coolest one of the
neatest things about working at snl is
getting to hear
you know don pardo say great dawn oh
what a voice and jason sudeikis
like it's just so great and what was so
funny was when i first came on because
it is a difficult name he's very
very sensitive to that and he comes up
to and he's like uh he's like you know
is it am i saying it right is it sedate
sudicus i'm like no it's actually
siddiques
sue dickus and i'm like no no that's not
that you're getting
further away further away don it's like
sedakis and so he's just
all right sudeikis i'm like that's it
and then he just sort of wandering away
just saying my name over and over
so there you go so they kiss sedakis
jason's today i saw him at the
commissary days later
yeah looking at him off and going soon i
don't
i don't doubt it the guy the guy loves
it and he practices it doesn't come easy
now i'm i'm curious the uh of course the
the audition process for saranet life
has always
mystified me uh a bit because it's such
a nerve-wracking
you get the experience and they say uh
all right we're thinking of of putting
you in the cast of staring out live
this legendary show and you go there do
i mean what did you audition with what
did you go in there
they usually make you do like some
original characters and impressions and
like uh
and some of the impressions actually
none of the things that i've done in my
audition because i auditioned
two separate times have i done on the
show and sometimes that that occurs
because
someone already does it on the show so
like i sort of you know goof around and
do like a decent you know i do a doctor
phil impression i i will declare it
decent as arrogant as that may be
uh but i you know and i can't do it
because daryl hammond who
does a much better impression believe it
or not right already does it so so like
it's wasted it's wasted and uh and uh
you know it's just simply
me just you know you know what you need
to do you need to understand that
sometimes people don't get the way that
the things they want
you know it's just a lot and all i'm
really doing is just my high school
basketball coach
that used to and then then just so lo
and behold a guy named dr phil came in
that happened to talk and act and be
and bully people just like my high
school basketball coach but he used to
be you know snake is where you're
supposed to be
it's like on the uh on the baseline sir
then get there
what the hell you doing up there you
look more nervous than a long tail cat
in room full of rocking chairs like my
high school coach used to say this
i've never met someone who actually said
things like he said and if you ask him i
bet he'd think he'd
tell you he wrote it too he's one of
those guys but you know in a good way in
a nice way but
you know dr phil you know it's all this
type of advice that makes no sense
you know i you know you can get people
to do what you want sure you can you can
get a dog
to bark by grabbing all those ding-dong
but you ain't always gonna get the kind
of bark you want you know you're sitting
there
you were down there a long time yeah you
know the dog
dog like yeah yeah your imaginary dog
disgust me
get some more there boy there you go did
you ever get to uh meet dr phil
no i've never met dr phil not yet i need
his help but i have not met him
uh the closest i i come is a degree of
separation
story one of those which you know was a
buddy of mine lives down in texas he was
down there you know uh uh
and uh he he's going across the street
he's got some headphones on
just sort of listening you know to that
sort of days and out uh and
starting across the street goes out
during a red light and uh here's this
you know this loud honk like get out of
the way idiot and uh
and he looks up and there's a yellow
ferrari looks up a little further big
middle finger looks up over to the
you know left of that finger and it's dr
phil
tell him to get out of the way wait wait
wait wait who who i mean you've already
won when you're in a ferrari and you're
honking the horn and a pedestrian to get
out of the way you've won
to then give them the finger yeah just
seems like a new low
why he's one of the great ones that's
why he's one of the great ones he takes
that next
yeah then he stopped the ferrari got out
and kicked your friend to dash
and threw a hundred dollars just in
there take that stay on the road dummy
well i just have to ask you okay you
haven't been in star not live long no
but but quickly favorite uh celebrity uh
interaction moment
and i mean like behind the scenes okay
um well you know
i get asked you get asked that question
i would say uh snoop snoop doggy dog i
mean i got to see some of
some awesome people you know from al
sharpton uh and uh will ferrell
obviously
but like uh but but snoop dogg is the
coolest
dude uh i used to write for the show i
wrote for the show for two years before
i i
actually got to be a cast member and we
when as you probably know because you
wrote there
you get to meet with them sure and you
get to talk about ideas and stuff with
them and you get to hang out with them
for like 30 45 minutes
sometimes like we did on this one
tuesday night and
he just drops little pearls of wisdom
just as cool as can be like we're
listening to
his songs like some of his great hits
like gin and juice right or uh nothing
but a g
thing sure and uh you know some of the
the great ones yeah and you know he's
like you know you gotta you know i put a
i put a cover on every album
because you gotta look forward you gotta
look backward before you look forward
you know all this is little knowledge
and then at the end my buddy rich who we
were sitting there talking
uh just joking around was like you know
snoop maybe saturday after the show we
uh
we got a party and a snoop like he
should he goes faschizel
right nice and rich joking around goes
you know hey yeah maybe
maybe we'll get a hoe and uh and it's
snoop just
on a dime goes why get only one hoe why
not two or three
he goes hey but that's not it i said it
gets even better
why get only one hoe why not two or
three don't put limits on your life
dream big you may never wake up
i couldn't believe it and then he got up
and walked out yeah
it doesn't get better than that just sat
there like we got to call urban
outfitters get that on a t-shirt make
some money
how do we turn this in right up there
with readings are right not a privilege
yeah
yeah what is like a vista view mountain
vistas excel to successors you know
dream big you may never wake up yeah
this weekend uh lindsay lohan is hosting
staring out live yeah
yeah i'll tell you later and musical
guess pearl jam pearl jam
jam good jason sudeikis
daniel powder stick around
you